they say a dog is man's best friend by
the way it's a woman's best friend too
and that is true for our next drew
gooder
b.j gainem is a former united states
marines who has made it his life's
mission to help veterans get the canine
companions that they need i love him i
love this story so much take a look
hi i'm bj gannon i live in madison
wisconsin and i serve the united states
marine corps for nine and a half years i
had to retire early because i was
injured while serving in iraq due to a
roadside bomb and i lost my leg below
the knee i now serve as the ceo and
founder of sierra delta
helping more veterans find innovative
ways to connect with dogs and help them
overcome the challenges that leaving the
military either expectedly or
unexpectedly can cost
when i was injured in 2004 i was
depressed
and in those darkest moments it was a
dog an old english bulldog that inspired
me to take ownership of my life
sierra delta is an organization
dedicated to help other vets find
connection with their dogs my dog dozer
saved my life flat out
veterans need our help and if we come
together we can find a way to not only
help the men and women who need a dog in
their life but we can help a lot of
these dogs that need good men and women
in their life as well
okay i am here with bj please welcome bj
everybody
thank you thank you
thank you very much you're awesome i
love reading about your story um you are
such an incredible person first of all
it is an honor to meet you
and i would love if you would share your
story with everybody in 2004
thanksgiving night
uh you know my career came to an end due
to a roadside bomb it killed my gunner
ryan contafio he's the c
on my leg here crows is the the five
marines that we lost
cantafio raymie o'donnell warrens and
simon
and it changed my life forever not for
the bad i had to go through some bad
stuff but we all go through bad stuff
but
it took a dog
to really help me take ownership of my
life
um and start putting one real foot in
front of a prosthetic foot
and he didn't do this with any
great training he didn't come from great
breeding i mean i bought him off
craigslist is one of the first purchases
i made on my first convalescent leave
because i wanted a bulldog and also
you've really explained to me
yeah um
about how to place people with dogs is
very customized also like you saw a flaw
in the system
talk to me about that because i really
loved your individual
approach about pairing a person with a
dog and you started this organization i
mean this is what you did with your life
right well with a lot of people that
were there to help me uh president bush
he calls me belushi i was part of the
portraits of courage but he told me he's
like belushi i can give five million
dollars any one of these dog companies
and it won't move the needle for the
veterans
and he was right and the thing is is
that all these dog companies are doing
great work we have one of our veterans
here with a great
service dog from one of our great
partner providers and southeastern guide
dogs right yeah
but
he's
there's only about a half a percent of
the veterans that need a leland type dog
the rest of us can really benefit from
what we call life buddy and it's
basically every other label you can do
and so uh we contract there's plenty of
dog trainers out there there's more good
people we're more great people in this
country
than we give ourselves credit for
what we're doing i agree yeah
what sierra delta is really doing
is organizing all these great people so
that veterans can access it in a
streamless way we have it on an app most
of the train most of the veterans that
come to us already have a dog so we're
already pairing them with the trainer
and we can get every dog to canine good
citizen for leland there's three more
tests after that
all of these veterans
we just spent
billions of dollars on taxpayer money to
train these veterans to not only be good
learners but good leaders
right so let's help them
learn how to communicate and care for a
dog in a way that's similar to what they
felt in the marine corps and give them
targets to hit
well um stephanie actually uh will you
talk to bj about how
he helped you in your life with leland
so i can't thank bj enough since june
2018 we've been on a wild ride together
with the service dog industry
i received leland
100 days after my date of discharge for
the military and that is unheard of in
the service dog world
he actually comes from southeastern
guide dogs in florida
and
i can honestly say that being able to go
out this morning and go try a new york
bagel by myself in the bustling streets
of new york city
would never have happened before i got
leland great that's awesome right
well i want to help and get involved and
actually we have a fellow veteran here
who heard about your story and wants to
help with awareness and connectivity
actually lana duffy come on out
[Music]
please have a seat
we thought that maybe you two should
meet because lana will you please tell
everybody uh what your company does and
obviously will you start with how you
came into doing your company yeah i
actually served around the same time
that you did and
was hit by a roadside bomb in iraq i had
a severe traumatic brain injury and i
had all these other
things going on so we
my company that i started it helps to
connect veterans and service members to
non-profits and services and benefits
and it's like a yelp for veterans so
people can
advise others
the other piece of what we do is we do
artificial intelligence analytics to
help
organizations and services
find ways to have more impact and so we
are going to offer
you a year of our analytics which is
anywhere between ten and twenty thousand
come on it's dollars what we need that's
exactly what we need
that said you still want to give you
five thousand dollars from the show and
i'm gonna match it so it's another ten
thousand dollars
actually we have a matching program
going on right now perfect december 1st
through the 31st and so this is going to
get mad so you're actually going to turn
it into 20 000.
[Applause]
and this is amazing like thank you i
really believe this is going to be our
breakout moment because we were on this
show because you introduced us to
thank you amazing thank you for letting
us get involved and tell the
[Applause]
ignite what you're story doing thank you
so much thank you stephanie and leland
and pj
we'll be speaking a lot more i can't
wait
[Music]
you